so in 2017 if you left a th000 bucks in
your bank account fast forward to now
2023 right they don't know that though
you [__] up now your now your 1,000 is
almost worth like 500 if you compare it
to Gold to me it always goes back to
okay at what amount do you cash out and
start using this cash because never cash
[Music]
out so Costco has recently sold $100
million in what the last quot Ki bang
wow Kirkland products no uh pumpkin pie
no roaches chickens no 100 million okay
wait no sorry the pumpkin pie should be
like 10 you guys are way off that's
crazy really dude oh man it's something
you never guess oh you know what it is I
saw Kirkland Vodka artichokes it's
Kirkland no it's not C M's cookies
before the Rebrand yes no it's not
artichokes no salmon it's not can you
check again if it's not I'm just hearing
what BART buys
cost no I don't buy arti shopping list
zip ties um water no Excedrin toilet
paper you guys have 20 seconds Optometry
Sur almond butter [__] do we have any
chance of getting hot dog sh Pizza 100
million think of it it's being sold by
something common yeah it's got to be
like a car car insurance they sell
jewelry garage doors oh wedding rings
close you're getting closer gold bars no
w
what Boolean kind of stuff wow where so
I didn't know you could buy gold at
Costco nobody does is it cheaper there
so so yes how that's why people are
getting it huh right well so Costco um
they just started selling gold bars
right and nobody really knows that
they're doing this but they're selling 1
oz gold bars right Swiss check this out
Swiss
made wait that looks like that's crazy
that's dope no that's a that's a bullion
company you know what I think it is cuz
when you buy gold or any precious metal
there's a company that has to verify it
and it costs them however much to verify
So based off of the company that
verifies it it could cost more or less
but it's Costco so they could be like
well here you go you know yep yep wow
this guy's into gold huh right maybe you
got a weird gold fetish man yeah what
the [__] I love
gold what are you a big gold buyer not a
big buyer but I did read a lot and watch
a lot videos of it because I was like
because I wanted to know like what other
ways can you have assets and then I mean
medals have been have been around
forever so it's pretty smart I used have
a lot of gold tight bro yeah so Costco's
been selling these 1 o gold bars it sold
100 million of them wow what nice and I
think it's really just kind of the the
lack of faith that people have in in
dollars right now oh yeah that that's
the reason why I started buying gold was
because I was like I hear about the
dollar tanking and cash is losing its
value but then that's where gold and
silver actually and time shares yeah
time shares all of them together but
it's power power thr it's still a risk
but it's a little bit lower risk because
the price doesn't fluctuate as crazy as
everything else so do you guys all buy
gold I don't um when I'm done buying
Herbal Life yeah I sold all of my gold
yeah really was there a reason why I
bought crypto with it oh and paid some
taxes did you did you like wait till it
went up then you sold uh it went up
enough and then after I sold it it went
super
up don't you love that it always happens
that way feel good as far as like I mean
I made a little money but it was like a
100 bucks it's like going up a little
bit I mean it's always very slow didn't
it break its past like highest peak yep
yeah uh so so Costco's selling 1 oz gold
bars for just over $2,000 a pop with a
limit of two bars per Costco member a
good price that's it it's pretty good
it's pretty good it's all right cuz you
yeah it's good for what it's costing now
yeah yeah that's why they sold so much
of it and and they put it up and it's
gone in hours wow wow because it's so
close what's what they call a spot price
which is kind of like what they measure
and if it's closer to the spot price TR
they charge a fee so like you can get it
for spot like if it's worth whatever the
market rate is you go to a jewelry shop
pawn shop whatever they all have their
own like transaction thing like 40 bucks
or whatever but some Jewelers will give
you
spot yeah some Jewelers will give you
spot so are people physically walking
out with this at a Costco like it's
usually online oh they get it shipped
that's D Dam it's like this big yeah
it's a little it's a little boy that's
crazy dude 1 o that's it but they also
use troy ounce so they don't use it's
not a true ounce it's like 30 something
to or oh is that right yeah it's not
like a regular
it's they go by the amount doen or some
[__] silver is also uh slept on too
because is it it's a jam yeah yeah you
just got to ask Ron Paul and Alex Jones
gems are slept on too rubies sure
nobody's Emerald
guy Jam geod totally slept on well when
you think about the dollar now right the
dollar is basically a contract that you
have when you when you start a job
anywhere the dollar is the idea that
faith that you have in it and if I if I
get a certain amount of dollars I'll be
able to turn it and do a certain amount
of things that will benefit my life but
they're just inflating the currency so
[__] godamn nobody has faith in that
so they're going here when you came up
on ethereum I forgot what year was maybe
2017 17 okay at that time I remember
talking to you we just barely met and
every December I buy gold and usually it
was the same like one oz of gold was one
Bitcoin back then it was like a th000
bucks I remember that and then now it's
like look at Bitcoin it's like yeah 40
Grand right now and then look at gold
it's like 2 Grand so it's Bitcoin
destroys gold dude yeah for sure but you
know who the loser is is the person who
saved a th000 bucks in 2017 so in 2017
if you left 1,000 bucks in your bank
account fast forward to now 2023 right
and then like that means they don't know
that though you [__] up now your now
your 1,000 is almost worth like 5 100 if
you compare it to Gold I'm learning that
right now purchasing power yeah you
can't buy the same [__] with 1,000 bucks
in 2017 you can buy like way more [__]
than now so it's like you definitely
can't buy that gold that you looking at
me to me it always goes back to okay at
what amount do you cash out and start
using this cash because in never cash
out yeah but that's the thing in you
just collect it like a leprechaun like
my I turn my $1,000 to whatever 5,000
whatever but if I take it out
anything in any like investment or
whatever like let's say you take it out
but then if you spend it it's the same
thing as like it's actually not no it's
not cuz you're buying an asset yeah so I
bought a house right me and Nikki bought
a house you guys you have a house you
guys have a house right so we bought
assets assets have been actually
surviving this inflation [__] because
it's all slated towards the assets right
they're they're making it they're
inflating your currency so that they can
accumulate more assets m you're talking
about when do you liquidate or when do
you sell your assets so you could use it
like at what uh moment do you go okay
this is high enough let me cash out and
spend on other Investments or whatever
like how do you know like what to do
with it cuz I bet you there's a bunch of
people that get there and go oh I'm
going to blow it all on what you should
have a goal that's what I always tell
people have a goal whatever your goal is
just write it down and I tell people
write it down don't put in a stupid
notepad write it down make it real take
a pen piece of paper and write it down
for yourself so it's real and then you
put it on your monitor you put it next
to your desk wherever and you look at it
every day and you manifest it like Joe
does you manifest it like Bart does you
manifest it like Ryan does you manifest
it like anybody who I like you did when
you said you wanted to to help people
and train people like if you Manifest
this stuff then it's it's not as corny
as it sounds what you're doing is you're
putting an an investment into this every
day and taking it seriously that's what
you're doing but people go go it's a
bunch of foo foo [__] what me they're
manifesting stuff oh yeah I'm just going
to think about it and not no you're
thinking about it and you're making it
you're taking it seriously that's what
people don't understand about
manifesting I think the lazy manifestors
are just thinking that you're sitting
there going oh I wish I'm rich it
happens for me yeah but I think like um
if I can use like psychology then it's
it's creating a cognitive bias so you
constantly see the red car see choices
yeah and then um you're looking for
solutions to get it that's right you're
taking it seriously yeah cuz if you're
reminded every single day like I need to
come up with 100 Grand right and then
you see that number and then you're
looking for gigs side gigs jobs how you
can increase your income and you don't
forget about it every day versus someone
that goes oh I wish I had 100 Grand and
then tomorrow they go you want to go to
the movies and you're like hell yeah y
but if you had that in front of you go
100 Grand nope the movie is not going to
help me I'm going to spend I'm I'm going
to need
$110 more and your friend is like hey
I'll give you 100 and if you have a goal
right and your friend's like I'll give
you 100 bucks to help me move
you you might be like oh okay yeah cuz
I'm trying to manifest towards that I'm
trying to get there and that would help
me get there but normal people go nah
right because you don't have that goal
set you don't do nothing else that day
there's no there's no intention you're
just doing [__] just to do it my friend
um had his goal I don't I don't know if
he actually graduated college but he was
like I have like all this debt and then
he's like okay what I'm going to do is I
got one year to make 50 grand and I'm
just going to do as many gigs on
Craigslist side hustles
whatever after his like regular job to
to to make 50 Grand with and he
surpassed it in less than 12 months and
he was just like I think he was really
young at the time too like he just
College age or in college or whatever it
was but he was like yeah it's just one
of those things that I had to kind of
try and like challenge myself and he
goes so I was like painting houses I was
taking out trash I was doing this and he
goes there's days where I made like a
th000 bucks in a day and I'm like what
so I'm like that's kind of a cool thing
to do where you have something and every
day you just chip away at it yeah yeah
Mark Bernett who who found a Survivor
very quickly he um he moved to LA
basically with a dream and then he went
to the beach and he just started he he
basically like paid for like um a corner
of a fence that he like bought t-shirts
threw them over the fence and he sold
them at 20 bucks a pop and like
obviously he would wiggle around but
like that's how he started and like made
like a small amount of money that way
that he ended up turning into a bigger
amount of money and parlaying that into
what became his producing career and he
[__] did Survivor So Co yeah he's
insane I think he did Shark Tank too
right I don't
[Music]
know